ogn inoby had 12 points in the game but
certainly the most important
three in the game winner with half a
second left here he is
yeah i made some in high school and
did i know i was in when i released it
yeah did it feel good it felt good
what were you thinking when uh go
through and also what do you think of
the past found
oh yeah kyle made a great pass he waited
long enough
and threw an error quick enough for me
to get it off before they got to me so
it was a great password
just what was the feeling when uh
obviously we talked
[Music]
just get ready for game four
we lost you there for a second can you
just repeat that like it was cool
and then just get ready for game four
now all right thanks
next we'll go to blake murphy
congrats on that man um i guess
so you right after you hit it you kind
of stayed stoic you didn't really react
but then
fred came and kind of gave you this
running hug and the rest of the guys ran
over
um did you kind of feel that point where
you broke and allowed yourself to like
enjoy it and smile a little bit like can
you tell that was happening
uh yeah it was like yeah i was excited
everyone excited for me still was cool
uh someone hit me in the nose
so i was kind of mad about that but it's
cool everyone's excited
i know this this is maybe a bit of a
random example but i remember back to
that
your first playoff run against cleveland
you kind of hit a big clutch
three uh in transition as well and you
guys didn't end up winning that game but
it was the same kind of
you know a little unexpected a huge huge
moment
um do you feel any connection to that
one or do you think that says anything
about
your confidence level at all oh uh i
mean
yeah it's kind of similar but we won
this one so this one's better
uh what what does it say to you that you
know your teammates
trust you enough to put the ball in your
hands in that situation
oh like it just makes me feel good you
know my teammates have confidence to me
always want me to shoot the ball the
coach is going to shoot them all the
time whenever i get it
so it makes me feel good just makes me
want to stay ready to shoot
do you demand a few mornings oh yeah
always
thanks
next we'll go to uh jeff silken from the
usa today aog thanks for a few minutes
um we wanted to hear what is
you know just what were your thoughts
leaving the huddle and watching boston
uh the play was for pascal to get a shot
and then they switched it up top and
then mark flashed
and i think jalen went to him on the
flash and then left me open
so yes it was all those actions that
took place that
left me open so
hello jeff good thank you
uh next we'll go to stephen from
sportsnet
mlg congrats on the win congrats on the
shot uh i just wanted to know like like
uh the play before
obviously campbell kind of dropped that
from that drive
they they got that drunk there you guys
took a time out
okay what was the mood like in in that
timeout
but can you can you tell us a little bit
what was discussed
for you guys yeah no one was right after
that everyone stayed confident the next
play
was focused on winning this play and
getting a good shot off
and we're confident anyone who took a
shot they could make it so
we're just looking for the next player
the group is resilient so
just next play mentality
thank you all right next correctly larry
from raptor.com
hey og uh maybe a stupid question just
watching like you just you showed no
emotion after you hit the shot like how
do you
how did you stay so cool after such a
big buck
oh like because when i shot i expected
to make it so like i don't shoot trying
to miss
like every shot i shoot i try to make it
so
i wasn't surprised because i wasn't
surprised
what did you what was your feel for i
guess you and the team's emotion
through the game it just just seemed
like it was so hard-fought it just
i guess yeah how would you assess the
emotion that you guys went through
through the neck
uh everyone will stay even killed like
we know it's a game of runs you know
we're going to run they're going to run
just take the punches keep going we make
our runs they make their runs
try to get timely stops and just just
keep going
next we'll go to manila rodriguez from
taft cortez
yes og from puerto rico um
congratulations on this chat
but how do you feel this win can change
the momentum of the
series which has been dominated by
deceptics for the first two games but
today you guys showed more courage and
you guys
got the win how do you think the
momentum changes
oh it's definitely a momentum changer
like even game two we thought we could
have won
we made some mistakes we felt we could
have won that game
so this game same thing we just won this
game and just
go out through the game plan win the
next game and just try to keep winning
uh next question will be julio nieves go
ahead
go gee great shot tonight as you just
mentioned uh
you kind of kept your cool after you hit
the shot
so as you just answered also i'm sorry
if i asked you the same question
how would this shot change the momentum
of the series uh
the confidence level has always been
there for the raptors right now
this shot kind of like is a wake-up call
for the raptors or
this will make you guys know that
you guys have whatever it takes to beat
the celtics now
it's not yeah like we we always felt
like we could
win so like like we're not surprised we
won
every game we feel we have a chance to
win we didn't play that well game one
but the game two played well
we just didn't win today we played well
yeah we didn't win
so we're just gonna go out there do the
game plan because we're always confident
all right thanks uh one more question
for you oh gee uh last one we'll go to
andres lopez
og congrats in the shot you guys hit
your back against the wall in this
series
and you really stepped up to the
challenge do you think that games that
go down to literally the last half
second like you did today
do games like this bring out the best of
you guys as basketball players
do games like this bring out the best of
us yeah like we're all competitors so we
all want to win
so we just played to the buzzer
[Music]
thanks suji